only a couple of hours ago we became
aware of um
a conversation with francis collins
who's the head of the nih
on lex friedman's podcast
and we've both listened but we really
have had very little time to to
think
carefully through the various ways to
respond i have
pages of notes that i am not going to to
riff on here um but for a couple of
points and you wanted to just say
something about one of the points
yes i want to uh
to do that i i should say i have not
gotten 100 through it yet i'm okay uh
probably an hour into it yeah i have um
i literally was not able to listen to
the last two minutes yet but i feel like
i got the chest
um and lots lots and lots maybe that
punch line is in the last two minutes
yeah maybe so
um
so francis collins is the he's been for
12 years the head of the nih spanned
three different presidencies
he is as the head of the nih of course
the employer of the boss of the heads of
all of the the sub agencies at the nih
including the niaid
which is the agency that that fauci
leads uh and
you know without going into all of the
details on the various claims in the
podcast this may not seem as strong but
one of the things that colin says in
this podcast is that in addition to
stars kovy 2 quote we have another
epidemic in this country it's the loss
of the anchor of truth
and
he of course is suggesting that it is
people who are questioning the
pronouncements that are coming out of
organizations like the niaid and the cdc
and the who
who are losing touch with the
quote-unquote anchor of truth
but given how many
how many untruths and illusions and um
sleights of hand
that he engages in in this in this
conversation
it would seem to me that he is exactly
the person who is contributing to the
epidemic to which he is referring
yeah it's perfectly ironic it is it is
perfectly i'm just i'm going to try to
stay cool here i
the other thing that i wanted to
specifically mention since we don't have
um
i'm
sorry
i'm not i'm i take back what i said no
no no this is not this is not on youtube
uh we decided that uh i should not be
let completely off leash today because
um i would i don't think it might be fun
to watch and i'd probably be um some
riveting and maybe a little cathartic
for me but i don't think it would
necessarily be the best use of our
platform near the end of the
conversation uh collins uses a metaphor
of being a midwife in this process and i
actually did not have time to go back
and um
remind myself of whether or not he's
talking about being a midwife in the
process of of kovid of the coveted
response or
of the entire um his entire time at nih
but regardless really there are enough
other things that he's done at nih that
um that no matter which one of those two
things he's referring to this um
at the point that he called himself a
midwife i think i almost punched a tree
i was out walking well while listening
and um
he's actually i think a better
metaphor than midwife uh would be that
he's the he's the doctor who comes in as
a a woman is um getting close to being
able to give birth um perfectly normally
and you know it's hard and it's
dangerous and uh the fact that we're
bipedal makes it uh makes it more
dangerous and more difficult the fact
that we've got giant brains all of this
is true and um
medical intervention has saved babies
lives and women's lives
but um most births don't require it and
he's actually rather than like a midwife
who is simply facilitating what was
already going to happen and helping it
along he's more like the doctor who
forces full medicalization
of birth he drugs the mom and he cuts
her open and he rips the baby out and
then he drags the baby away from the mom
maybe doesn't let baby near the bomb um
for a little while and then and then
when the baby uh doesn't attach at the
breast or is otherwise a little impaired
for having had this incredibly traumatic
birth experience he blames the mother
that's what he's like not a midwife he's
like that doctor
and this is um
just how how dare he call himself a
midwife really well i actually kind of
want to steal man his position oh go
yeah go for it now my thought is that
what we have is a completely disastrous
public health policy in response to this
pandemic has been from the beginning and
collins has been in a position to do
something right about it which he has
failed to do again and again
um
it is
not as much
um
his catastrophe as it is directly
anthony fauci's collins is fouchy's boss
and so
i would say
that um
fauci is more like the mother of this
crisis
and
uh
collins um
it's a midwifed crisis let's put it that
way
midwife crisis
you don't get it
oh no
my joke has fallen flat midwife crisis
oh oh see all right yeah i don't like it
though i i get it now but i don't like
it i mean hey um
i came in the door
i'm full of adrenaline right now but um
but i also i guess i don't um
you know
midwives
have been vilified you know not not so
recently like you know by the time we
were young adults i think midwives were
coming back into fashion it was sort of
understood that the medical it was
beginning to be understood that
medicalization of birth had been
way overdone and that midwives having
been you know pushed out in favor of
high intervention um high credential
doctors was uh was maybe not the right
move um but i guess i don't want to um
neither of them
neither of them have been midwife-like
right right no i i i mean but this is
this is this is
this is why some people don't like puns
right it's like oh okay i get what you
were trying to do but no no some people
don't like puns i know
nobody likes puns unless you're making
them right yeah dick alexander used to
say that the
uh the person who was the butt of the
the pun was the person listening to it
um
that's good yeah yeah that's probably
right that's a very insightful guy um
but anyway yeah so all right this this
midwife thing is a way that people
distance themselves from responsibility
you know it was happening anyway and and
it's sort of falsely humble but in this
case actually he deserves responsibility
and responsibility for what is in effect
an upside down response where we've
missed virtually every opportunity we
had to do something useful and embraced
all sorts of things that don't make any
sense
and
anyway it was very disturbing i mean
he does
appear
to be
guileless
and yet almost everything he says in at
least the first hour of this podcast
strikes me as
distorted warped misleading it was it
was a remarkable display there's a lot
of very precise language uh that is
delivered as if it just occurred
yeah it's a very precise language is a
good way of of putting it
and a fair amount of cfa i noticed
throughout what's up uh cover fouchy's
ass um he did a lot and he did it about
as well as a transparent miniskirt
you could see right through him oh no
yeah i know oh no
okay i would like the audience to
recognize that that image that is now in
all of our heads was not put there by me
i didn't do it
didn't do it wouldn't have done it i
wouldn't have done it you know the funny
thing is i said it without having the
image in my head and now you have forced
me
to see that i don't think that this is
my you know i i'm i'm neither midwife
nor dime i'm just i don't feel like
maybe we should not belabor the point
good one well done
yeah no you have no responsibility dude
you're like the
the 60s husband in the waiting room
handing out cigars to rando strangers
look what i'm doing
okay exactly
i should say
putative father in the waiting room
ah
did you want
were you going somewhere else no no
really i think i was i think it was
there you didn't want to i thought you
maybe wanted to say something about that
you would said oh yeah oh uh you you
were done with your point all right so
we could move on to that uh that point
so one of the things that he does here
um is he
attempts to cover fouchy on this issue
of gain of function where of course
fauci lied directly to congress with
cameras running
some of us saw it right away you can
check my tweet from
uh from that moment and which
point i said this is just a flat out lie
no but brett
i mean my eyeglasses are going to
function so yeah
every day i have a gain of function
because i'm wearing these eyeglasses
otherwise i would not be seeing you as
clearly i'm happy for that gain of
function so collins does this amazing
thing here which is he basically argues
that gain of function is effectively
meaningless because virtually everything
that we do that works is a gain of
function so that's not what we science
types mean by gain of function we mean
something very specific and so narrow
that you almost couldn't possibly meet
the definition and then he tells us more
or less where the bodies are buried
literally in this case um
what he says is effectively look gain of
function in the regulated sense only
applies to human pathogens and because
we're talking about bat viruses
you know yeah we're not talking about
gain of function in the gain of function
sense although we may be talking about a
gain of a function no it's very highly
regulated there's only been three
influenza viruses in the last several
years that have been authorized to
and therefore right and this is uh
nonsense and really its purpose is to
lead you to believe that there's some
very technical discussion that you are
not qualified to understand and
therefore fauci has been simply
insisting on a technical definition that
you couldn't possibly care about and uh
you know rand paul has been going after
him based on common parlance and it's
like all some kind of scientific
misunderstanding it does depend on what
the definition of is is it it it sure is
um
yeah yeah
it's it's similar level of definitional
games games yes games uh in which you
know that reference to um clinton being
impeached in
1996 whatever it was
um you know the only thing at stake was
actually his presidency which to him was
obviously incredibly important but
people weren't going to die over it
but in this case
these definitional games are of far
greater impact tremendous impact and
they are a matter of responsibility so
uh
he also does a lot of stuff you know he
makes the standard
play he says
that
although a lab leak is
possible it's very unlikely based on
exactly zero evidence of course
and actually
lex asks him if um
if this is a matter of science if we
will ever if there's any way that we
will actually ever know about the origin
and colin says well yes it's quite
possible we will know and alex asks him
how
and he says well if we find the
intermediate so basically the point is
he has set up a circumstance in which
only one side of the equation is
testable if it turns out to be a
natural origin then we can prove it and
there's nothing that can prove the other
direction and so and and the whole thing
is just nonsense because we've we can
see
in the uh the grant application that was
recently revealed by eco health alliance
where they wanted to enhance pathogens
the entire argument for the research
program involves enhancing pathogens so
we can understand how they work before
the pandemic strikes us from nature so
the the whole thing is nonsense he's
just creating a false story and through
the entire thing he strikes this
um this
uh stance in which he is the beleaguered
scientist forced to engage an ignorant
public and yes that's his cross to bear
and he will do so willingly so long as
in the end the public comes around to
the pronouncements of the public health
authorities who have of course been
right from the beginning when in fact
they've been wrong again and again and
again and again and they've been
revealed to be hiding things again and
again who most especially fauci again
and again and again and so why is
anybody listening to this guy
why is anybody listening to this guy he
is lying into a camera in order to
mislead you back into a story that has
fallen apart around him
yeah
and um
there are a lot of those examples in
this conversation um
which we're not going to pursue here
right right we will
allow our eyes to bulge privately
um
good for now yep
all right uh i did actually want to
segue to the next thing we were going to
talk about uh with uh
one additional thing uh that he said
that collins the head of the nih said in
this conversation so how do we
uh solve this thing how do we get out of
this pandemic what's like if you had a
like a wand or something or
uh you could really implement policies
what's the full cocktail of solutions
here oh it's a full cocktail it's not
just one thing
in our own country here in the u.s it
would be getting those 64 million
reluctant people to actually go ahead
and get vaccinated there's 64 million
people who didn't get vaccinated adults
yes not even counting the kids wow 64
million wow isn't that astounding
get the kids vaccinated hopefully their
parents will see that as a good thing
too
uh get those of us who are due for
boosters boosted because that's going to
reduce our likelihood of having
breakthrough infections and keep
spreading it
uh convince people that until we're
really done with this and we're not now
uh that social distancing and mask
wearing indoors are still critical to
cut down the number of new infections
but the full extent of his answer is
vaccinate everyone
including children
socially distance
wear masks
that
is
it
that is the full extent of the answer
that he provides for how we can stop
this pandemic
he must know that's not true
he must know he has been the head of the
national institutes of health for 12
years okay
how else
can we actually control this pandemic
how can individuals actually take
control of their own health
besides getting vaccinated and wearing
masks and socially distancing which are
the three things and and making sure
their children get vaccinated if they
have young children these are the only
things that he says individuals can do
in order to help control his pandemic no
he is wrong and he knows he's wrong
eat real food
move your body supplement with vitamin d
if any of the following things are true
for you if it is winter where you live
if you live at high latitudes if you are
obese if your skin is dark if you are
sick in any way but especially with any
of the comorbidities for covid
there are a tremendous number of things
that people can do to actually take
control of their own health and by doing
so the outcomes for covid the chances
that you will get it and the chances
that you will get really sick from it go
down dress dramatically dramatically
another thing that he says in this
conversation which is not true that um
that you're that your health doesn't
have an effect on
on covet outcome it's it's it's a it's
dead wrong and he knows it
[Music]
you